mercredi midi kerwin rentrer du collège
elle a 11 ans et habite cet immeuble de
la chaumière dans les rampes de saint
françois à saint denis
nous
[Musique]
et voici sa main
alors c'est dépassé elle vit à l'excès
syfy dans ce petit appartement donc
keisha elle a 10 ans les deux soeurs
participe depuis trois ans au projet
demos sa selle au début chacune a reçu
au palais c'est de qui c'est deux clones
demi après deux semaines de vacances la
reprise est difficile
[Musique]
et
m
espace mais c'est pas accorder ça
m'énerve ça fait combien de temps que
les filles vous jouez donc ça est ce
qu'avant ça est ce que vous écoutez de
la musique classique
pas du tout ça vous a surpris se
retrouve embarqué dans cette histoire là
oui oui et au début c'était comment as
tu été mis d'accord ce bruit mais ça
faisait pas que c'était comme ça faisait
ça ça faisait ça quand on est accueilli
charmante rappelons le violent comment
ça faisait le sens des bus reprenait
c'était terrible début parce que des
bruits cris des bruits à la maison et
des fois où ma tête et fatigue et
d'écouté après jeu et on va déranger les
autres je compte que je n'explique ce
que vous voulez au début vous avez
accepté de leur avoir dit oui
elle vous étonne dans leur façon de
s'impliquer dans ce projet là mais là
maintenant ça ne plaisait au téléphone
comme ça
et j'ai envie qu'ils vivent loin
[Musique]
carwin et caixa en répétition dans cet
après midi
deux fois par semaine elle se retrouve à
l'école candidats zemma dans le quartier
des camélias
[Musique]
les deux soeurs font partie d'un groupe
de 15 enfants du quartier encadrés par
deux professeurs de musique
[Musique]
avant de commencer on vérifie si les
instruments sont bien accordés
[Musique]
on va faire cordes et enfin
et
et tout de suite debussy sonne beaucoup
mieux
oui
mais
vraiment la progression de sa soeur
honor 2 ans avec ça vous ce programme là
vous prouver que la musique classique ça
peut être pour tous
[Musique]
tous mes amis
oui
je crois que c'est nul et qu'est ce que
tu racontes
[Musique]
jacques piette fait ça
trois jours plus tard nous retrouvons
qui ruine et caixa la cité des arts pour
toute une journée de répétition cette
fois avec l'ensemble de l'orchestré
demos
[Musique]
sa seule personne
ce matin les enfants pour d'abord répété
la partie chants et danses du concert
qu'ils donneront dans moins d'un mois
maintenant à la philharmonie de paris
[Musique]
à
ensuite place à la musique sous la
direction de denis l'apôtre chef
d'orchestre au conservatoire
au menu du jour nous allons consacrer le
début de la répétition à debussy
[Musique]
ils sont à présent plus de 100 à jouer
les 80 enfants du projet demos renforcée
par une vingtaine de musiciens
professionnels
[Musique]
à paris ils auront un défi
supplémentaire
il faudra jouer debout et même valser un
deux ou trois je me ressens un deux
trois après 1 et
[Applaudissements]
à paris les enfants de la réunion
présenteront aussi l'enfant monde une
oeuvre originale du logiciel label qui
mêle sonorités classiques électro et
percussions de puniet au coeur de ces
partitions c'est le funky there has awa
qui a écrit le texte de la partie chant
en se basant sur le vécu des enfants des
enfants venus de tous les quartiers de
saint-denis sainte-marie et
sainte-suzanne des enfants qui ne
semblait pas destiné à la musique
classique et qui à paris pour enchanter
fièrement d'où ils viennent et quel
chemin il parcourt depuis qu'ils ont
intégré le projet des mosses
[Musique]
et